hello everyone and welcome to the game a
lot of you guys requested in the
comments of the previous video I wasn't
sure about showing this game but I
decided to show it one it is a beautiful
game and two a lot of you guys requested
it it's round two of the Dos Manas
Tournament of 1996 and vishan Anand with
the white pieces faces then world
champion Gary Kasparov and um if you
guys remember in 1993 Kasparov uh split
from F along with Nigel short they
formed a professional chess Association
and uh you had two world champions at
the time one from the professional chess
Association one from the the the FED
lineup and at the time uh when Kasparov
split Anatoli karpov became fed World
Champion by defeating Yan Tean later on
gatak kamski later on I think he played
against Anand and uh yeah you had two
world champions but I'm pretty sure
everyone considered Kasparov to be the
absolute strongest player in the world
so this is a great opportunity for honor
and the white pieces against the world
champion let's see what happened here
and I will explain the name of the title
at the end of the video so Anand with
the white pieces opens with Pawn to E4
now Kasparov was known to play many
things but uh you know his Knight of
Sicilian was always you know a thing to
be feared Knight to F3 uh D6 we have
Pawn to D4 captures uh captures captures
and now Knight to F6 Knight to C3 and
Kasparov goes for the Knight or
variation of the Sicilian Pawn to A6 and
even today and in those days you had
four main moves against the n Bishop to
E2 Bishop to C4 Bishop to E3 and Bishop
to G5 which are still the the top four
moves today and if you are a n of player
you have to be prepared at least for
those four so Bishop to E3 this is the
English attack and pawn to E6 by
Kasparov they transposing into the KH
variation of the Sicilian and now again
F3 and Bishop to E2 are the top two
moves Anan goes for Pawn to G4 he wants
to dislodge the Knight with Pawn to G5
uh again an idea very popular even today
h six stopping that and now Pawn to F4
we have Pawn to E5 Kasparov says all
right easy with those pawns let's
resolve the situation in the center
first and Anan plays Knight to F5 he
says okay if you want you can capture
this knight uh but if even if you do so
yes you will double my pawns but my
pawns will be very very impressive and
G5 is uh definitely coming so instead
after Knight F5 Knight to C6 by Kasparov
and now Queen to F3 very rapid
development on the can Castle Queen side
next G6 attacking anand's Knight on F5
and Anand does not move the Knight he
just castles Queen side and he says you
have the Knight I will have the attack
and okay you have to capture the Knight
G captures on F5 and now uh what do you
capture with do you capture with the G
Pawn or with the E Pawn you know when
first we're thought how to play chess we
are uh thought to capture towards the
center sort of to improve our Central
presence but here this wouldn't be all
that impressive if you capture with the
Jeep Pawn uh you no longer have the
option of playing G5 and black is
actually very happy here so instead e
captures on F5 was played preserving the
possibility of G5 and now uh it's
kasparov's turn to act how do you how do
you react to this uh well uh the I will
show you the absolute best line because
the absolute best line is so complicated
that I think uh neither of them wanted
to play it or maybe an had it prepared
since he went for this with the wide
pieces but uh okay you could go Rook to
G8 that's very nice you could play e
captures on F4 but the absolute main
line is Bishop to D7 and now the point
is if you go Bishop Pawn to G5 it's not
uh that strong because after e captures
on F4 G captures on F6 you will play F
captures on E3 Queen captures looks very
nice as you have the pawn guarding D7
square but there's Knight E5 and the
White's attack is over not nothing to
worry about here you're going to move
the queen castle Queen side and
everything is fine however if after
Bishop to D7 you go Bishop to G2 then it
becomes a lot more interesting what can
Kasparov do next well of course he wants
to move the queen castle Queen side Rook
H to E1 let's say castles Queen side and
now Pawn to G5 H this is what you get H
captures F captures now Knight to D4
attacking the queen and now not Bishop
captures but rather Rook captures on D4
and now after e captures and Bishop
captures spinning the knight uh Bishop
to C6 attacking the queen here Queen F1
and now Rook captures on H2 pinning
Bishop captures on C6 Queen captures and
Bishop captures on F6 attacking The Rook
Rook d8 offering a trade uh everything
will get traded off captures captures
let's say queen to C4 check King to B8
and something like B3 and the game
continues with um Kasparov being up the
exchange but Anand having the
possibility of creating a pass Pawn on
the king side all in all it's equally
you know with perfect play probably
black is better but over the board when
the clock is ticking white might have an
edge here
so that that's what you have to decide
on here but Kasparov said I want none of
that he played Pawn to E4 and this
complicates uh matters drastically now
what can Anan do of course he has to
capture he played Knight captures on e4
Knight captures Queen captures and now
Kasparov just offers a queen trade to
stop the attack but Anan said nope not
so fast Queen to D3 okay Bishop to G7 uh
and now Bishop to D2 Anan wants to shift
the bishop over to C3 to counter Asar of
Bishop on G7 and Kasparov castles King
side he goes in front of the pawns and
Anand now starts the attack and he
doesn't even prepare he doesn't play
King to B1 or Rook to G1 the usual moves
you play before an attack he just uh
lounges forward with Pawn to G5 and okay
H captures we have F captures and now
Queen to E5 very annoying attacking the
F5 Pawn twice and also threatening
Checkmate on B2 so how can Anand avoid
this well uh Pawn to F6 he gets rid of
the weakness on F5 and also cuts off the
queen and the bishop uh and now what do
you play here uh if you move the bishop
let's say you play Bishop to h8 now
Queen to G3 and Kasparov is uh well
Hanging On by a threat here for example
Bishop to F5 you're going to attack the
queen and once the queen moves Bishop to
D3 with you know the H4 the H Pawn
marching forward if G6 is played this is
game over so instead Kasparov starts
with Bishop to F5 of course a crucial
Tempo attacking anan's Queen and Anan
plays Queen to G3 and uh interestingly
there is only one move that saves
Kasparov here and it's not one that uh
you know instinctively comes to mind so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only move for Kasparov here to
survive this position while I give you a
couple of
second so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on uh on
achieving uh well this level of Mastery
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it is Rook F to C8
this is the only move and the reason is
you have threats here once The Rook
moves to C8 again if if you just play
Bishop to h8 we go into the exact same
line Bishop to C3 Queen C5 Bishop D3 and
there's not much for black to do here
like you go Rook eight T8 uh you're
going to trade here Bishop captures
Queen captures Rook H to F1 the queen
has to move and now okay Rook F2 you
stop Rook E2 and now you will start the
advancement of the H Pawn and black will
will really struggle to survive this
however after Rook F to C8 it's very
tricky can Anan take the bishop on G7
and do you even want to take the bishop
on G7 what happens if you do if F
captures on G7 what did kaspar had in
mind of course you open up the C file
now with a triple attack on the C2 pawn
and that's pretty much it white resigns
here because only move that defends is
Bishop to C3 but it only defends for a
few moves Knight captures with check
King B1 Knight captures with the check
again B captures Rook captures and now
uh well either you trade queens or you
get checkmated but even if you trade
queens and it is equal material for the
moment but the G Pawn will fall uh and
then the two Rooks and the bishop will
be too strong against the the white king
also the pawns will start marching
forward objectively this is winning for
Kasparov so instead after Rook F to C8
Bishop to C3 by Anand uh waiting for you
know preemptively striking against
Knight to B4 and now it Kasparov to make
a move what do you play here your queen
is under attack obviously Queen trade is
the only thing you have you can't really
do anything else um if you if you put
the queen to a silly Square then even
just a nice F captur and G7 is
sufficient but what happens if you trade
Queens here if you trade Queens here
then look at this H captures on G3 and
now again Knight to B4 just extremely
annoying you can't move the bishop and
allow Rook captures on C2 so we will
play A3 and now after Knight to A2 check
King to D E2 Knight captures and C3 B
captures uh what do you play now well
the problem is you can't really save
your Bishop let's say you go Bishop to
h8 then comes Rook to H4 and after Rook
to C5 hoping to move the bishop
eliminated the G5 pawn and then
hopefully the F6 Pawn Here Comes Bishop
to D3 attacking your Bishop here and
once you capture on D3 and it seems like
a great move you're going to capture on
G5 next nope Rook D to H1 and now how do
you avoid checkmate you have to put the
bishop back on G7 uh it's disgusting I
know but it has to be done C captures on
D3 and now you have this position work
as part would still be up a bishop but
he would have to give it up there's no
way to avoid Checkmate even if you put
the bishop on f8 you still get
checkmated so we're going to see Rook
captures and G5 F captures and G7 King
captures and equal material this should
be this should be a draw uh so
incredibly complicated stuff and that's
why after Bishop to C3 Kasparov does not
play Queen captures and G3 R he plays
Knight to B4 he sacrifices his Queen and
now again it's time to calculate I mean
I'm sure you guys are fed up with this
game by now but imagine two of them
playing this game every you know uh
trading Blow by blow every move like
they get surprised and then they have to
calculate all over uh okay there's no
other move you have to capture the Queen
Bishop captures on E5 is played and now
kaspar plays Rook captures on C2 with
check King to B1 and now look at this
you have all sorts of nasty discoveries
possible any move with the Rook is a
nasty Discovery or okay you don't really
want to play Rook captures on B2 but any
move other than that is a really nasty
Discovery and you know the the world is
your oyster so what do you do here uh
kaspar played I'm not going to tell you
what he played first let's see if you
can if you can take the queen Rook to G2
how is Rook to G2 checkm well with
Bishop to D3 but you don't really want
to capture the queen right away because
then Bishop captures on F5 and white is
just up too much material what you want
to do here is play Knight captures on D3
again threatening so many nasty
discoveries and only after the queen
takes the Rook now you play Knight to E1
check with another nasty Discovery and
now you take the queen and after King to
A1 you're going to take the queen and
after let's say Bishop captures on D6
you're going to finally move this bishop
the Bishops will get traded off captures
captures and now something like Rook to
D2 and you have two Rooks uh Against The
Rook Knight and Bishop uh but all in all
should be uh should be a draw I mean you
could play it but the the Rooks are just
too active and it's very easy to pick up
those pawns even though you have a
knight and Bishop Against The Rook
objectively it's a draw so instead after
King to B1 Kasparov uh well uh knew that
he could not go for this he played Rook
to E2 with check stopping Bishop to D3
and now there is only one move for Anand
of course it's not King to C1 if you
play King to C1 the Knight captures on
A2 is Checkmate in one uh Rook covers
these two squares and the bishop also
helps out along this diagonal and the
Knight delivers check on C1 so instead
he plays play King to A1 and now of
course you know what happened next the
king to a uh Knight to C2 check was play
King to B1 and you could choose any
check with the Knight kaspar played
Knight to the A3 check and he was in
this position un move 25 that Anand and
kaspar agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here the the
position will just get repeated King A1
Knight to C2 check King B1 Knight to A3
check or Knight to B4 Knight to D4
doesn't really matter but it will be a
three-fold repetition uh so yeah uh
that's the game and uh oh yeah first
when I asked you do you guys want to see
it I I said it was a 25 move draw
doesn't seem like something exciting
that you should see but now you see that
it it's actually one of the most
exciting games of the tournament and
that you definitely should see it and I
call the dance of the Dragons because uh
well not so long ago in the world rabit
and Blitz Championship we had that game
of nepo and dubove where they had their
dance dance of the nights that ended in
a draw fairly quickly but now you see
what it looks like when you have the
dance of the Dragon and also the game
ends quickly in uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I'm just
going to show you the standings if
you're just tuning into the tournament
but yeah the tournament Was Won very
nicely by a shared first place Kik and
toal of won with six six out of nine uh
Anand and Kasparov shared the sort of
second with five and a half out of nine
um Kasparov losing that incredible game
to kramnik and Anan losing two games but
he did get four wins then the Local Hero
Mig ilas Cordova we've seen a game he
played against Anand in the previous
video absolutely incredible stuff do
check it out if you haven't ksky gelfan
ivanchuk pogar and last place or rather
Shar last place Yuri pluger and Alexi
shirov uh so that's the game those were
the standings hope you guys enjoyed that
I would like to thank welv Sasha vidler
Mark Henley Brandon Michael mes and
Frank Banner for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos there thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day